RFK Juniors sticking it to the
Democratic party and Joe Biden during a
Hannity Town Hall the candidate vowing
to stand up for free speech on day one
of his presidency and to end the
weaponization of governments
I want to end that polarization and I
want to do that by telling the truth and
the first step we have to take is to
tell the truth of somebody have a
president who's willing to tell the
truth about everything
people people
in this country know that the system is
rigged and they know that they're being
lied to I'm going to issue an executive
order the moment I get into the White
House the first day for bidding
ending the weaponization of our agencies
for political purposes
RFK Jr also giving bed wedding Democrats
more reasons to be nervous after he
openly questioned Joe's Fitness for
office he's never been very good with
words decisions that are coming out of
the White House are bad to decisions
right and you know they uh the
Democratic party does not censor people
in my experience
um we're not the party of War we're not
the party of the neocons dictating
foreign policy
We're the Party of the middle class and
we're the party of working people and
that's not where the party is anymore
and proving RFK Junior's point on
Biden's words the president just made
this stunning Claim about cancer
if you could do anything at all Joe what
would you do
I said I'd cure cancer they looked at me
like why cancer because no one thinks we
can
that's why we can
I mean and the cancer as we know it what
yeah that's that's a new one we ended
cancer as we know it Dana RFK kept it
classy he wouldn't go make any personal
attacks on Biden he disagreed obviously
with a lot of his positions
um but is it possible to win as a
Democrat today while criticizing the
White House well it's
um he he does keep it classy but he is
going after Biden in a way that exposes
the weakness so if Biden were a stronger
front-runner there would be much less
oxygen for RFK but the Biden White House
they barely make any news if they are
making news it's about taking away your
freedoms and appliances and that's and
they're so focused on climate change
then they're having to answer lots of
questions they're on the defense on
their back foot on Hunter Biden and
they're trying to tell us that
bidenomics is working and if you look at
the polls that's absolutely not the case
but chaos loves the vacuum right and so
RFK Jr is filling that spot I've always
maintained that if RFK really wants to
be president he should run as a third
party because in the Democratic primary
he's not going to win it's just not like
the Democrats don't like him a lot of
Republicans might like our conservatives
or people who are unaffiliated to 40 of
the country says they're independent
they're not Republicans Or democrats and
he could speak to them and I just don't
understand I understand why he doesn't
there is family tradition and that is a
big big deal to leave your party but
there's you know some people today
saying wow even the Boston Globe went
against him but the Boston globe's been
going against RFK for quite a long time
even members of his own family yeah have
been going against him it's but it's the
I think this shows the fact the RFK is a
little bit he has shades of Bernie
Sanders where you can give Joe Biden a
really hard time but when it comes down
to it the Democratic machine the party
is going to stick with their front
runner you know Harold the quest what
Dana just positive is was my question to
you and that is I mean given the fact
that uh you know RFK uh thinks that his
own party has gone too far left is he a
a candidate for a third party uh in this
presidential election should he be
um I don't know I know he's running in
the Democratic primary I think Dana's
right I think Dana's right on that point
and I think Dana's right that there's a
vacuum at the White House President
Biden if I were part of that campaign
team I'd have him out once or twice a
week giving big speeches on where the
country is and where we're going and how
his leadership is going to help Advance
us there when I listen to RFK Jr at the
start of his campaign we talked about
him here uh and Greg I thought talked
eloquently about him and his candidacy
from the standpoint of of he's speaking
to a part of the country speaking to
middle class aspirations and values I
don't agree with him on his position on
the war but he is veered in the last few
weeks talking about conspiracy theories
if you look at his polling data he's
come down a little bit in the polls and
I think the vaccines and even the the
words about Israel and Jewish Americans
that's not why I think people were
interested or tantalized by his campaign
from the outset if he wants to get back
to the Kennedy Camelot mode he's got to
talk again about those middle class
family issues those middle class
aspirations and values and how the
wealth Gap is worsened and what he will
do to address that I don't think what
he's doing now is helping to advance his
campaign you know uh Greg 65 percent of
Americans think that the countries who
divided one of the reasons Joe Biden was
elected is because he said he was going
to unify us
um if that's the case why are so many
people supporting Biden and not RFK
team sport perhaps but he did say two
things that were interesting to me the
system is rigged and Americans are being
lied to who does that sound like exactly
Donald Trump yep thank you Harold yeah I
thought it was a quiz yeah yeah yeah
yeah but before before I pay compliments
to Kennedy I gotta I gotta say that you
have to I have to bring up what uh
Jessica says that when Republicans
Embrace someone who's running for
president on the other side you should
suspect it's not purely for altruistic
purposes so I mean a lot of a lot of
Republicans really do like him but it's
probably because he you know he could he
could really hurt Joe but the problem
with the party and I this is why I think
he should run as a third party candidate
because I do think he should he would
win is because his party's radical
elements uh you know what we call the
woke have embraced this fascist
clampdown on language which is what we
were referring to if you have opinions
that that that aren't uh accepted by
that group they will come after you they
will try to destroy are you it's one of
the most substantial political and moral
flips in history recent history where
the party that fueled the Free Speech
movement is now fueling its opposite
it's incredible I mean they they talk
about the Banning of books and they
can't cite one but they are constantly
targeting people for speech for language
opinions all the time the White House is
going after private citizens over speech
it's incredible so I think that I also
wanted just one last one I do think you
know I thought it's analysis of the war
was dead on we don't talk about the war
that much anymore because there's not a
lot of good news coming out of there but
and it's hard for conservative
Republicans and you know to to admit
that America has a role
in this happening 20 years ago I
wouldn't buy into it but the world has
changed and he's challenging my
assumptions and I think he's child I
think he's in a weird way another flip
you're saying Republicans who are
becoming anti-war and Democrats pro-war
I mention one thing he has a net
approval of plus 12 which is a lot
higher than Joe manchin so if you were
Joe manchin's thinking about running as
a third party that's another data point
okay okay Jesse so even as Republicans
come to rfk's defense and and I you know
I hear a lot of things that I I like too
and I think a lot of Americans would
like his polls have been down does this
show how much the media is uh you know
it it has allied with Joe Biden and the
administration I don't know if there are
down that much
and there's room for him to improve
because we're just getting started but I
don't believe anything these politicians
promise at this point when you get in
there and you promise to end
polarization that's not happening I mean
they've been stoking this is my fire
poker
move this polarization for two decades
with social media right it's going to
take a generation for us to maybe even
try to start liking each other and then
he's going to say I'm going to come in
and I'm going to end the weaponization
of government on day one
by an executive order yeah nice try I
think the FBI and the CIA are going to
have something to say about that and
he's going to be a president to tell the
truth well we had a president that told
the truth and they investigated him and
impeached him twice again good luck with
that but when Greg's saying there's an
overlap there's an overlap in its
building from the left from the right
it's populist and Americans agree I'd
say 70 percent they're anti-crime
they're for a secure border they are
pro-middle class they have a little bit
more of an isolationist tilt to them
there's that juicy middle in American
politics that they don't want to Foster
because that breaks the system in half
but if if we can get it together we'll
get there
okay hey Sean Hannity here hey click
here to subscribe to Fox News YouTube
page and catch our hottest interviews
and most compelling analysis you will
not get it anywhere else